Dieses Gejammer. Ich finde es ja auch immer so gut, wenn man bei einem, ich schreibe ja gerade meinen Roman, und ich finde es immer so gut, wenn man da einfach andere Worte für Sagen verwendet. Also wenn man nicht sagt so, jauchst du. Oder zum Beispiel, hey, kann ich bitte mitkommen, jammerte Stefan. Und das ist aber du kannst eigentlich jedes erdenkliche Wort statt Sagen machen. Hey Leute, Stephen King hat gesagt, das sollte man nicht machen. Echt, wirklich? Man muss das Wort sagen lösen. Niemals irgendwelche Phänomen davon. Und daher, herzlich willkommen zum Podcast UFO. Wir wurden entführt, wir sind in einer grossen Lagerhalle, wir können mal ein bisschen die Kantons beschreiben, die um uns rum sind. Wir wissen nicht, wie wir herauskommen. Es ist stockdunkel. Wenn ISIS diese Bekenner-Videos hochlädt und so, dann klingt das immer von der Autoaufnahme ungefähr genauso wie hier. In so einem halligen Raum, so Gruften oder so. Wir sind jetzt in der Tropfsteinhöhle Hagen, haben wir uns zurückgezogen. Wir schaffen es auch von Folge zu Folge, uns technisch wirklich konsequent zu verschlechtern. Aber wir werden doch immer auch rumgeschoben in dieser Firma. Wir sind so ein kleiner Dampfer auf so einem großen Ozean. Und Mächte sind am Werk, die können uns nicht beeinflussen. Die beeinflussen uns, wir können nichts dagegen tun. Und wir sind jetzt irgendwo in so einem Raum gespült worden, in so einem kleinen Schiffchen. Ich fühle mich manchmal so wie die orange Begehrtkugel, die da so ruht und dann plötzlich klok, klok, klok, klok, klok. Und dann kommen ganz viele andere Kugeln und dann wird man rumgestotzt und dann ist man da und man wird selber nie gedotzt direkt. Ich fühle mich wie eine Pinballkugel, die so, man weiß nicht genau, ich habe Pinball auch nie ganz verstanden, hat man da, ist es ein Skillspiel, hat man da, muss man, weiss man, was für Punkte gibt und so? Das ist ganz schwierig, das ist ein ganz schwieriges Teil, sprudelte Stefan, aber im Grunde, es ist glaube ich schon ein bisschen Skill dabei, verriet Florentin. Sprudelte aus Stefan heraus. Gipfelte Stefan. Aber du kannst jedes erdenkliche Wort. Jauchzte. Auch wenn es dann keinen Sinn ergibt. So wie Mampfte. Es ist tendenziell eher im Essensbereich, im Nahrungsbereich angeordnetes Wort. Auch im Bewegungsbereich. Schnell, wir müssen uns vereilen. Hetzte Stefan. Fuchtelte Florentin. Das ist jedes erdingliche Wort. Ich muss ein bisschen zugeben, ich bin ja oft dir abgeneigt. Erkannte Florentin. Körperlich, aber auch mental. Aber ich habe bei mir manchmal, entdeckt man ja so Regungen in einem und denkt sich, warum mache ich das eigentlich? Du hast ja auch auf mich einen runtergeholt. Tief unbewusst möchte ich so sein wie du. Ich will du sein. Ja, könnte man an den Bose-Kopfhörern merken, könnte man am Juhl merken, könnte man an den Stephan-Tieze aufdrücken, an den Fatou könnte man das merken. Und an den Fehlkäufen. Ich habe nämlich bei mir gemerkt in letzter Zeit, ich habe ein bisschen Scheiße gebaut. Ehrlich jetzt? Ich habe mich finanziell ein bisschen in den Roggen gelegt, muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen. Du hast dir dieses leerstehende Schloss gekauft, in dem wir uns gerade befinden. Ich habe es ersteigert. Viele Adlige sind tatsächlich mittellos mittlerweile, was viele nicht wissen. Mittelte Stefan. Und deswegen dachte ich mir, ich greife da einfach mal zu und ersteige mir für 16 Euro dieses Schloss, Os, Os. Grunzte er. Und jetzt bin ich hier gefangen. Nein, es ist so, ich wollte mich mal so ein bisschen weiterbilden, musikalisch auch mal neue Horizonte erschließen. Und ich habe ein neues Instrument für mich entdeckt, das Automaton. Und ich will mal nur so viel sagen, viele Leute sagen immer, wo ist denn das Intro, wo ist denn das Intro. Und deswegen möchte ich jetzt hier in Folge 108 feierlich euch sagen, es wurde leider nicht geliefert. Es wurde nicht rechtzeitig geliefert, es wurde angeblich hierher geliefert, ich habe keinen Schein bekommen.
Und gestern war ich, ich habe dann diese Mail bekommen.
Du hast keinen Schein bekommen, frage Stefan.
Ich habe nur einen Erpresserbrief bekommen, antwortete Florentin.
Ich habe einen Erpresserbrief bekommen, so, wenn sie in zwei Tagen ihr Paket nicht abholen, wird es zurück nach Japan geschickt, was mit einem Todesurteil gleichkommt.
Jeder weiß, Pakete nach Japan geschickt bekommen, ist ein Euphemismus für Nackenschuss, weiß jeder.
Weiss jeder. Hast du das verstanden, wo du gerade Erpresserbrief sagst? Entschuldigung, ich will dich nicht
rüde unterbrechen, gab Florentin Stefan an. Gerüttelte Stefan. Gerüttelte Stefan.
Ne, folgendes, warum muss man aus verschiedenen Zeitschriften und Zeitungen Buchstaben ausschneiden, um dann einen Erpresserbrief zu geben? Bevor ich dir die Antwort gebe, möchte ich erstmal drei mögliche Antworten von dir hören. Warum du denkst, dass es so ist? Interrogierte Florin. Antwortmöglichkeit eins, Unterhaltungsfaktor der Serien und Filme. Für den Erpresser oder für die Erpresserfamilie? Macht eine harte Zeitung. Für die Leute, die von außen die Situation beider Leute mitbekommen. Anfälligkeit zwei, damit man nicht erkennt, welche Zeitungen er gelesen hat, gekauft hat, das nicht zurückverfolgen kann, dass man nicht weiß, aus welchen Magazinen, da ist vielleicht auch örtliche Magazinen oder so. Aber warum macht er überhaupt das mit dem Magazin? Ja, damit man seine Handschrift nicht erkennt. Ja gut, aber man kann auch was am PC drucken. Ja, ich glaube, mittlerweile macht das auch niemand mehr. Das kann gut sein. Ich habe natürlich einen Trailer gesehen von einem deutschen Film, wo das mal wieder zum Vorschein geholt wurde, was ich nicht verstanden habe. Ja, vor allem, ich meine, das Auffälligste, was man... Das Problem des deutschen Kinos, dieser Erpresserbrief. Eigentlich das Beste, was man bei einem ersten Date zu Hause rumliegen kann, auf dem Klo, ist so eine Größe Hör zu, wo so einzelne Buchstaben ausgeschnitten sind und das Date fragt sich so, was ist da so? Alter, Motten, Ah, der Motten, ich habe ganz schlimme Motten hier, die zerfressen mir immer die Zeitschriften. Die schmeißen mir immer die Eurozeichen und die Zahlen. Ja, und die Achtjährige. Und es ist so, ich habe das Paket in zwei Tagen, und es ist natürlich, da habe ich Mitleid in zwei Tagen, ich will, dass das Paket zurück nach Japan geschickt wird, deswegen fuhr ich zu der Paketstation, die auf der anderen Seite der Stadt war. Da dachte ich mir schon, hm, merkwürdig. Ich würde sagen, wenn ich ein Paket liefern kann, werfe ich es erstmal in Reihen, werfe ich es über den Zaun. Da wird die Paketverfolgung auch dann so langsam in Reihen mitverfolgt. Oder ich bringe es in die nächste Paketstation. Deswegen kam es schon komisch vor. Ich bin da hingekommen und dann erstmal, ich bin ja der, ich bin immer so der, ich tauche komplett
ohne Ahnung auf. Es ist immer so,
ich tauche auf. Auch aus dem Nichts wie so ein Geist,
der zu Weihnachten erscheint. Genau, aber es ist so ein,
so, ja, ich habe,
ein Paket von mir ist hier. Ja, wie heißen Sie denn?
Ich komme gleich nochmal zurück
und kann Ihnen das beantworten. Ja, hier ist
mein Führerschein. Ja, was ist denn die Lieferungsnummer?
Ich bin in zehn Minuten nochmal
nochmal hier und komme gleich wieder. Es war tatsächlich legendärerweise, also gut, wer mein Buch gelesen hat, kennt die Geschichte schon, aber als ich mein Studium offiziell beendet habe, weil ich zur Frank-Erzner Masterclass nach Berlin gegangen bin, bin ich da zu diesem Studiumstypen gegangen und habe ihm gesagt, ja, ich möchte das jetzt hier beenden, das hat keinen Sinn mehr, Philosophie, die meisten sind seit 2000 Jahren tot, ich habe keinen Bock mehr. Und dann meinte er so, ja, haben Sie denn eine Bestätigung schreiben von dieser Masterclass? Und ich so, ich bin in der halben Stunde noch mal hier und der hat mich echt angeguckt, so als, du Depp einfach, kommst hier völlig ohne irgendwas. Ich weiß auch nicht, warum das machen muss, aber auf jeden Fall bin ich dann nach Hause gefahren mit der U-Bahn, bin nochmal gekommen und warte dann nochmal vor der Tür. Und der meinte dann auch so, ja, mein Bruder hat sich früher mal bei einer Frank-Elstner-Sendung, Nase vorn hieß die, hat der mitgemacht, da hat der Michael Jackson imitiert. Und ich so, okay, cool, cooler Bruder, also der eine Bruder wird Philosophie-Professor, der andere macht in der Fernsehsendung Michael Jackson nach. Aber das ist eine interessante Familiengeschichte. Noch lustiger wäre diese Analyse gewesen, gab Stefan an, in dem Moment, wo der Philosophie-Professor wirklich auch diese Philosophie-Weisheiten dann in solchen Situationen raushängen lässt. Imitieren wir nicht alle jemanden, imitieren wir nicht vor allem uns selbst? Oder so psychoanalytisch wird. Was will uns die Unterbewusstsein damit sagen, dass sie vielleicht das daraus vergessen haben, um sich hier nochmal zu besinnen, dass sie nicht diesen Job annehmen wollen, sondern weiter studieren wollen? Brauste Stefan. Auf jeden Fall war ich dann bei der Paketshop und es stellt sich raus, mein Paket ist nicht da. Es ist einfach nicht da, es ist weg, es wird nur zurückgeschickt. Auch was man nicht versteht, Pakete, oder? Warum kommen Dinge an überhaupt? Wie ist das überhaupt möglich? Pro Tag kommen Milliarden Pakete irgendwo an und werden verschickt. Ich habe letztens einen Brief an eine Bank geschrieben mit einem vorgedruckten Ausdruck und da ist dann so die Adresse drin und dann soll man das so einpacken mit so einem durchs durchsichtigen Fensterbrief. Du hast nicht gefaltet bekommen, dass die Adresse genau in den Fenstern ist. Das ist eine Geschichte, aber dafür mehr in meinem Buch. Und zweitens stand da nur Bank, wir nennen sie jetzt mal die Money, Money, Money, Money Bank. Und dann stand da nur Money, Money, Money Bank Nürnberg. Und that's it. Keine St it. Keine Straße, keine Adresse. Auch das Prinzip Postfach. Postfach. Postfach wurden nur für Gewinnspiele erfunden. Postfach Pokémon. Ja, klar, der Postbeamte ist da. Ach, übrigens, Leute, das ist für Postfach Pokémon Gewinnspiel hier. Noch besser als Kenboard. Kenboard. Kenboard Sonne. Zu Händen von Pikachu.
Leute, ist die Ding, wohnt hier in Kennwort Sonne? Lächerlich. Ich bin in Car2Go hingefahren und war im Parketshop und musste dann fünfmal nochmal zum Car2Go zurück, weil ich auf meinem Laptop nachgucken musste, was in der Mail stand.
Und dann gab es die Situation, dass ich mit meinem Macbook Pro auf dem Dach eines Car2Go's in der Innenstadt von Köln stand.
Und ich habe mich noch nie so metropolit gefühlt wie in dem Moment.
So ein Laptop, kreativ, on the way, auf dem Dach des Car2Go's in der Innenstadt von Köln stand. Und ich habe mich noch nie so Metropolit gefühlt wie in dem Moment. So ein Laptop, kreativ, on the way, auf dem Dach des Car2Go's. Und das auf dem Dach eines Starbucks. Total, im Hintergrund der Kölner Dom. Ich dachte mir so, das ist so ein Foto für Medienstandpunkt Köln. Das ist so eine Werbung von der Stadt. Voll Idioten wohnen in Köln. Blockieren den Verkehr. Warum machen Städte eigentlich Werbung für sich?
Also, dass man sagt so, kennt ihr Aachen?
Nö. Aachen ist sehr attraktiv. Wir haben viel zu bieten, wir haben
eine Universität, wir haben
Wohnungen. Im Grunde ist
eigentlich jede Werbung gleichzeitig
eigentlich
ein Eingestellnis der Unbedeutsamkeit,
weil man sagt, Aachen,
wir müssen Werbung machen. Und jede Werbung für eine Stadt zeigt, wir sind so dumm, wir sind so unbekannt, wir müssen Werbung machen. Die coolsten Sachen machen Werbung. Berlin sollte eigentlich so ein Ortseingang gestellt haben wie so, herzlich willkommen in Berlin. Wir brauchen Sie nicht. Ja, genau. Sie sind egal. Oder Berlin macht Werbung für Baden-Baden. So weißt du, wir sind so cool, wir können sogar Werbung für eine andere Stadt machen. Wie hinten auf Büchern. Und trotzdem kommen die zu uns, weil ihr uns so geil findet einfach. Wie hinten auf Büchern. Ist auch ganz okay, Berlin. Ja, zum Beispiel, ich glaube, die wirklich die erfolgreichsten Produkte sind die, für die keine Werbung, nicht deswegen, aber für die muss man keine Dosen-Ravioli. Hast du jemals in deinem Leben eine Werbung für Dosen-Ravioli gesehen? Alle kaufen Dosen, lieben es, umsatzstärkstes Nahrungsmittel. Aber auch Mercedes hat einfach seinen Standpunkt perfekt im Markt erschlossen. Die haben genau diese eine Customer Group, die immer Mercedes kaufen wird. Und die werden auch nachwachsen und Mercedes kaufen und so. Trotzdem machen die andauernd Werbung. Ich denke mir auch, wer kauft deswegen jetzt Mercedes, weil er diese Werbung jetzt genau sieht. Das frage ich mich generell bei vielen Werbungen, also warum kauft man jetzt danach das Produkt, weil auch so ein Auto, ich gucke doch keine Werbung und sagt dann, ah, ich kaufe mir jetzt für 35.000 Euro ein Auto. Ja, das ist die Frage, aber es ist ja auch oft so, dass man tatsächlich an Stellen Werbung macht, wo nicht die Leute sind, die das dann kaufen sollen. Zum Beispiel, wenn du in der Apothekenrundschau machst, du keine Werbung für einen Mercedes, obwohl viele alte Männer sich Mercedes kaufen. Aber wenn es in der Apothekenrundschau ist, dann denken die uncool, du machst Werbung im Playboy für Mercedes. Weil alle Leute, die im Playboy denken, denken, das ist mega cool, cool, Männlichkeit. Und die kaufen dann in 40 Jahren, wenn sie keinen Playboy mehr lesen,
aber das Geld haben, dann kaufen sie sich ein Mercedes
und du hast davor schon Werbung.
Lustigerweise macht man auch oft Werbung nicht für die Leute,
die das dann kaufen, sondern die, die die Leute, die es kaufen, beeinflussen.
Ja.
Kinder zum Beispiel.
Viele Leute, viele miese Schweine, wie ich sie nenne,
da kann ich mich nicht mehr an mich halten.
Polterte Stefan.
Also furchtbare Menschen, die richten dann die Werbung an Kinder, weil Kinder ihre Eltern beeinflussen, was sie für Tornister kaufen und so und so weiter. Hattest du jemals einen Tornisterwunsch eigentlich? Wurde er wünscht, erhört auch der Wunsch. Klasse 1 bis 4 waren Dino-Tornister. Ja? Ja, aber er war ein bisschen so ein postapokalyptischer Dinotonister,
wo dann auch
die sich gegenseitig angefangen haben, so
Feuerbälle. Auch so Laseraugen?
Laseraugen, ja, ja. Auch die Welt war auch so
eine Lava-Welt, so eine Lava-Welt.
Ich glaube, es war ein Scout.
War es so Scout oder For You? Scout,
immer Scout. Nee, das war nicht
die Frage. For You oder Eastpack ist die Frage.
Und Scout,
und dann gab es noch was anderes.
Mit diesem Hund drauf.
Nee, diese ganz boxartigen, diese ganz eckigen.
McLeod oder so. Keine Ahnung, ich weiß nicht.
Aber ich glaube, über die Deko
deines Tornisters kann man die Zukunft voraussagen.
Was glaubst du, was ich für
ein Muster auf meinem Tornister hatte?
Ich hatte auch so ähnlich wie Dinos, also in dem Stil,
auch so was bildhaftes, motivartiges. Vielleicht kommt einer da draußen drauf. Der würde mich mal interessieren, ob es jemand errät. Ratet jetzt, welches Motiv hatte ich auf meinem Schulrand als Kleinkind. Mittelalter, ein Schwert oder so. Einfach in grossen Lettern, ich werde für immer Jungfrau bleiben. So war es vielleicht. Niemand mag mich, ich bin fett und werde gemobbt. So ein grosses Eis. So ein Kick-Me, es ist schon imprägniert einfach so, man muss es gar nicht mehr hinkleben. Oh, danke. Nein, und ich bin gespannt, ob jemand die Lösung hatte, und zwar das Motiv meines Schulranzens waren Eisbären. Wenn Sie das gewussten, dann schicken Sie uns mit dem Kennwort Podcast-UFO an die Postleitzahl, Tister, an die Leindekastrasse 27 in Köln, Postleitzahl 8868 mit dem Kennwort Scout.
Tatsächlich Eisbären, so eine Eiswelt Arktis mit so Eisscheulen und da waren Eisbären drauf.
Blau fand ich schön, Eisbären fand ich gut, Boring, wer designt sowas, welcher erwachsene Mann sagt, ich designe, ich weiss, was Kinder wollen.
Die Worte sind in der Mitte der Welt. Blau fand ich schön. Boring. Eisbären fand ich gut. Boring. Wer designt sowas? Welcher erwachsene Mann sagt, ich designe, ich weiss, was Kinder wollen. Die wollen Dinos oder die wollen Eisbären. Eisbären sind super. Nein, Gary, die Leute wollen das, Kinder, was wollen Kinder? Kinder wollen Tetris, Flamingos, Nein, die wollen Game Boys, die wollen Super Mario, die wollen Game of Thrones, die wollenackte Kalees, die da drauf haben. Okay, ich hab einen neuen Entwurf. Sonnenblumen. Die Leute lieben Sonnenblumen, natürlich! Die Firma For You will sie nicht mehr beschäftigen. Einen einzigen noch. Tucker. Tucker? Sauber. Alle lieben Tucker. Wusst ich's. MC. Habt ihr euch jemanden Fragen? Hat noch jemanden Fragen zu diesem Improvisationsstück? Dinos gegen Eisbären, ey. Ich weiß nicht, wie es hier ging, aber als wir gerade in diesen Raum betreten haben, es ist ein grosser Raum, länglich, länglich, länglich, länglich. Und ich habe mich, es ist ein Tisch drin, der ist komplett leer, so ein Möbel befreit. Ich habe mich an die wandnahe Seite gesetzt, um den ganzen Raum, weil am Ende des Raumes ist ein Tisch, und ich habe mich an die wandnahe Seite gesetzt, um den ganzen Raum zu betrachten. Das gibt es ja, Leute, die sich auch immer hinsetzen, dass sie die Tür sehen müssen. Ja, und ich muss das machen, tatsächlich, weil ich habe immer gerne ganzen Raum vor mir und ich kann das nicht gut, zum Beispiel auch in Restaurants ist immer die Frage, Bank oder Stühle? Bank. Immer Bank, oder natürlich, weil du immer an der Wand sitzen willst, weil da hast du alles im Blick und es ist mir auch irgendwie klar geworden, weil welche Menschen haben die Steinzeit überlebt? Ich glaube, entweder die, die geflüchtet sind, die ängstlichen Leute, die mal in der Ecke saßen, den ganzen Raum im Blick hatten, die ganze Hülle im Blick hatten und geflüchtet sind und die Leute, die stark genug waren, um den Sebelzahntiger im Arm drücken zu besiegen. Ja, und die, die Glück hatten. Und die Glück hatten. Heute sind Menschen überdurchschnittlich glücklich, also im Sinne von Luck. Auch in 10.000 Jahren kannst du Lotto vergessen. Die gewinnen alle, die ganze Zeit, alle gewinnen sein Lotto.
Das setzt sich durch als Merkmal in der Evolution Glück haben. Du bist auf jeden Fall die dritte Variante, ich bin die ängstliche erste Variante, die immer in der Ecke der Höhle kauert und die auch nicht schläft, weil sie Angst hat, dass sie überfallen werden. Ja. Hat das jetzt irgendwie trauriger gemacht, als es klingen sollte.
Du hättest auch einfach mit einem Lachen wenden können, dieses kleine Bild. Dafür sind die Zuschauer da. Ich bin da, um mich um dich zu kümmern. Stefan. Also ich habe auf jeden Fall keinen Automaton. Es wurde zurückgeschickt, es ist wieder weg. Mein Traum ist gestorben, es ist vollbracht. Ich finde es lustig, wenn es so ein kleines Gesicht ist, dass er auch eine Note Smiley. Genau, so eine Note und auf dem Ballen der Noten ist ein Smiley.
Wenn dieser Smiley durch diese Reisestapparzen irgendwann anfängt, so ein böses Gesicht zu machen, weil so ein trauriges, weil es macht so ein schreiendes Geräusch. Ja. So ein ...
Wenn ich jetzt so ein ...
So ein genervt ...
Oder es fühlt sich in Japan so an wie der ... Bep, bep, bep, bep, kriegen Fünfer auf die Kralle, einfach hier schön, schön, fuffi auf die Kralle und dafür kriegst du es erst in zehn Tagen. Das ist sozusagen die Zeit, weil das ja für die einfacher dann, wenn die es nicht so lange brauchen, bleibt Geld übrig. Für die Autisten jetzt, oder was? Für die Autisten, ja. Ja, finde ich nicht schlecht. Stinkreiche Autisten. Diese neue Elfenbeintür, wo sie mit niemandem sprechen und immer noch noch eine Jacke mehr anhaben, als nötig ist. Es gibt ja jetzt eine Serie auf Netflix, Atypical, über einen Autisten, das reingeschaut. Toll. Sehr verletzend, glaube ich, für Autisten. Aber ist das nicht die Idee, dass die das nicht checken, so emotionale Sachen? Du meinst, dass man über die eine verletzende Serie machen kann, weil die das eh nicht verstehen? Oder weil alles verletzend ist? Ist das eine Gruppe, die man beleidigen kann, die, wo es nicht schlimm ist, wo es moralisch nicht verwerflich ist, weil die auch nicht verstehen, dass man nicht verstehen kann? So ähnlich wie Eskimos, wo du die halt beleidigen kannst, wo du dir sicher sein kannst, dass jetzt sicherlich kein Eskimos wird. Noch 50 verschiedene Wörter für Arschloch. Ja, 50 verschiedene Wörter für ich spreche kein Deutsch und habe keinen Internetzugang. Und deswegen kann man die auch nicht erreichen. Deswegen ist es egal, man kann sich locker oder so lustig machen. Das ist kein Problem. Die haben 50 verschiedene Worte für Schnee, aber ich wette, die haben keins für, sagen wir mal, Jura. Ich glaube, ich habe sogar über Atypical einen Artikel gelesen, weil es tatsächlich in der Autisten-Community auch so ein bisschen, einerseits, die finden es natürlich cool, dass es autistische Figuren gibt, mit denen man sich identifizieren kann, um da so ein bisschen Aufmerksamkeit dafür zu merken.
Aber auf der anderen Seite ist es auch dann so, dass der Autist dann so ein bisschen der quirky, adorkable Typ ist, der halt so cool ist. Adorkable? Ja, adorkable. Dieses Ding ist echt cool, das ist ziemlich gut. Michael Cera ist adorkable, das ist so sein Ding. So dieses, und dass man dadurch halt immer so eine Figur zeichnet, die dadurch halt immer so übermenschlich fast liebenswert und sympathisch ist und so, dass du halt dann eigentlich, um eine adäquate Darstellung, die einfach als normale Personengruppe zu akzeptieren, müssen die auch mal Arschlöcher sein oder halt auch mal irgendwie uncool, aber so ist es halt immer so, ah, der Autist, das sind auch die, die immer so verträumt und so ein bisschen kreativ und sich nicht trauen.
So süss, auch wahnsinnig gut aus.
Und so ein bisschen schüchtern.
Auch immer, als es professionellen Schauspielern gespielt wird, die sind immer auch wahnsinnig gut aussehende Menschen. Im Endeffekt sind sie einfach, wir hatten Autisten in der Stufe und ich sage nur, das war für alle ein Horror. Vor allem für den Kaktus, den er gießen sollte. Ja, vor allem für die Fische Susi und Bobo, die beiden was waren das, so Salmler Fische, die gefüttert werden sollten, tja, überfüttert nach einer Woche. Das sind die wahren Opfer des Autismus eigentlich, das stimmt schon. Rückblickend war der Bio-Unterricht seltsam, wo ich plötzlich eine Woche lang nicht am Unterricht teilnehmen sollte, sondern mich um das Schul-Aquarium kümmern sollte. Es fällt mir gerade so ein, dass es wahrscheinlich eine Woche lang, was hast du den ganzen Tag gemacht dann? Also einen Monat lang musste ich statt Bio-Unterricht das Aquarium sauber machen. Und da war ich einfach nicht im Unterricht, weil der Bio-Lehrer auch unser Klassenlehrer war. Vielleicht war das dann die Sexualkunde und du hast nie gelernt, wie Babys gemacht werden. Ich habe nur eine Aquaristik-Age, die es nicht gab, Credit bekommen. Du wusstest immer nur so, okay, junge Mädchen lernen sich kennen und gehen und dann Katsu und dann kommt das Baby raus und du immer so, was passiert dazwischen? Ich habe keine Ahnung, was dazwischen passiert. Und dann hältst du einmal Händchen mit einem Mädchen mit 29 und dann, oh fuck. Ganz wichtig, wenn man so aus allen Schulbüchern so eine Seite rausreißt und alle sowas, ja Polen angegriffen und dann Normandie, aber was war dazwischen? Das war dazwischen? Keine Ahnung. Ja, das war ein Problem, aber dafür kenne ich mich sehr gut mit Blaufisch seinem Land aus. Aber ich gucke nicht, ich habe jetzt wieder angefangen mit der besten Serie der Welt, Dr. House. House MD ist wirklich eine unfassbar gute Serie. Wo schaust du die? Netflix. Aber gibst du noch bis zum Eindriss. Ich habe gerade angefangen, mal wieder zu gucken. Und Netflix sagt, setz die ab. Eindriss der August. Netflix ist echt die moderne Karotte. Du bist immer vor deiner Nase und dann ist es weg. Ja, aber hast du manchmal das Gefühl, du klickst es jetzt an, dadurch wird jemand darauf aufmerksam und löcht es deswegen? Das ist so ein bisschen wie, wenn Freunde Geburtstag haben bei Facebook und du, ah, mit dem bin ich noch befreundet, entfreunden. Deswegen überdurch sind die viele Leute, werden an ihrem Geburtstag entfreundet, was einfach ein bisschen dramatisch ist. Ja, manchmal habe ich das bei Pornos. Und dann guckst du das und danach ist es weg. Aber in dem Moment haben sie das gelöscht, wo ich mir denke, habe ich die jetzt darauf aufmerksam gemacht, dass es dann Kinderporno öffentlich zugänglich auf YouPorn gibt. Und das haben die dann deswegen gelöscht, weiß ich nicht. Das kann sein. Naja, und House ist eigentlich, ist mir mal aufgefallen, die Serie macht nämlich einen grossen Fehler. Und zwar ist, House ist einfach der coolste Chef aller Zeiten. Er widersetzt sich der Regeln, er ist unfassbar zynisch, lustig, unfassbar viele Gags hat die ganze Zeit raus, verpackt alles in mal ein lustiges Spiel und alle hassen den. Das ganze Team hasst den kontinuierlich und die ganze Zeit wird gesagt, das ist ein riesen Arschloch und so weiter. Und wie kann man nur unter so einem Chef leben und viele kündigen dann auch im Laufe der Serie, weil die nicht mehr unter ihm arbeiten wollen und so weiter. Aber im Prinzip ist es einfach der coolste Typ der Welt, nur im Serienkosmos erzählt man den die ganze Zeit als der böse Mensch, aber das macht eigentlich nicht so richtig Sinn, auch wenn man die ganze Zeit für ihn mitfiebern und so weiter. Und eigentlich ist das Team die ganze Zeit das Problem, weil die ihre privaten Scheißprobleme auf die Patienten übertragen und einfach furchtbar sind und die ganze Zeit immer alles an den Patienten auslassen und die ganze Zeit wegkrepieren. Das ist interessant, wenn so eine Serie ein Gefühl behauptet, das man selber nicht hat. Ja. Immer so, er ist immer so erst der Gefürchtete und man denkt sich so, ich fühle so nicht gerade, ich lasse mir das jetzt auch nicht sagen von dir. Ja, genau. Ich rufe gerade für den, ich bin auf seiner Seite. Ja, oder vielleicht ist man auch einfach ein Psychopath und denkt so, naja, der hat schon auch seine Gründe. Und denkt sich so, die Serie will ja eigentlich was ganz anderes und dann hält sich mit Leuten, ey, haust du so ein Arschloch, oder? Wie der Mensch seine Assistentin umgeht und du so, ja gut, sie nervt aber schon. Aber es ist auch schon, ja. Oder? Auch wenn man dann, wenn man für Hannibal Lecter ist. Ich glaube, dann hat man ein Problem. Meinst du? Weiß ich nicht. Gute Filme schaffen sie natürlich auch, da eine Identifikation zu schaffen. Ist natürlich auch so die Faszination des Bösen und des Verbotenen. Und man schaut ja auch Filme, weil man wissen will, wie das ist, Psychopath zu sein. Und so kommt ja David Fincher jetzt auch bald eine neue Serienkiller-Netflix-Serie raus. Ja, das wird großartig. Mindreaders, Mindbenders, Mindslingers, Ratete Florentin, sowas in der Richtung. Ach ja. Serie, ne? Überall Serien. Überall Serien, aber man kann es ja auch nicht mehr, es war ja so das Neue übers Wetter reden, so, man weiß nicht mehr, was man sagen soll mit den Leuten, auch wenn man abends mit Leuten redet. Das beschreibt mich ganz gut. Du kannst nicht mal über Smalltalk reden, wie ich über Leute. Genau, richtig. Und dann hat man dann halt über Serien gesprochen, aber irgendwie gibt es mittlerweile so viele Serien und alle gucken was anderes, dass das nicht mehr möglich ist. Du kannst nicht mehr über Serien sprechen. Das ist ein Problem. Ich frage mich, was das neue ist, das neue Gesprächsthema. Podcast geht so ein bisschen langsam in die Richtung. Podcast könnte sein, ja, so ein bisschen, aber ist noch nicht so ganz hundertprozentig, selbstverständlich. Ich glaube, es ist meine letzte Podcast-Uvo-Aufnahme. Tod? Ja. Ich werde sterben. Ich habe jetzt mittlerweile seit einer Woche ein unfassbar starkes Flimmern in meinem linken Auge. Und das ist wirklich so eine dieser Sachen, die jemand, die googelt, halt innerhalb von, man ist komplett totgeschrieben. Und dann habe ich jetzt hier bis morgen einen Augenarzttermin, wo ich mir auch dachte, da haben die alle gesagt, nee, wir haben keine Zeit für sie, wir sind komplett voll, wir übernehmen gerade auch irgendwie einen anderen Arzt und es ist Urlaubsvertretungen und im Moment ist auch Stosszeiten, deswegen können wir sie nicht aufnehmen. Stosszeiten für Augenärzte? Ja, im Sommer. Im Sommer. Weiß ich nicht. Wegen Allergien oder was, oder? Ja, oder weil gerade, weiß ich nicht, weil gerade die Vögel... Die Sonnenfinsternis war doch gerade, die Hornhaut weggelasert so, und die Augenärzte so, wo, Sonnenfinsternis! Wir lieben Sonnenfinsternis! Soll ich da so Brillen tragen? Nee, lieber nicht! Nein, schrie Florentin. Alles weggebrotzt. Übersteuerte Florentin. Naja, und dann habe ich mich auch gefragt, was muss ich haben, damit ihr mich aufnehmt? Ich habe ein Flimmern, meine Sicht ist eingeschränkt. Vielleicht geht es allen anderen auch so schlimm. Was haben die denn? Wahrscheinlich habe ich einen Hirntumor, der mich auffrisst von innen und ich sehe nicht mehr auf einem Auge. Was, ich bin 22 Jahre alt, ich sollte sehen. Du meinst aber nicht blinzeln, oder? Wie? Das ist halt immer so ganz kurz schwarz wird. Das ist immer ganz kurz schwarz. Ja, aber das ist ganz normal. Das sind deine Augenlider, die so kurz durchflippen. Das hat die nämlich auch gesagt, aber dann hat die das von den Stosszeiten gesagt. Und dann hat die gesagt, tut, tut, tut. Naja, jedenfalls habe ich dieses starke Flimmern. Und dann ist mir aufgefallen, dass Online-Diagnostik echt ein Problem ist, weil du... Finde ich ein ganz spannendes Thema. Das Ding ist nämlich tatsächlich, wenn du etwas googelst, dann googelst du nach dem Symptom. Also du sagst zum Beispiel, ich habe Augenflimmern. Dann gibt es einen Artikel auf netdoktor oder gutefrage.net, da steht dann Augenflimmern. Das kann folgende Krankheit sein, folgende Krankheit sein, folgende Krankheit sein, folgende Krankheit sein. Die werden einfach ganz kurz, wird Krebs, Krebs, Superkrebs, Hyperkrebs, wird alles kurz angedeutet. Hyper-Aids, Ultra-Aids. Das Problem ist aber, dass du eigentlich Artikel zu Krankheiten lesen müsstest, weil die äußern sich ja nur durch bestimmte Dinge.
Das heißt, wenn du Hyperkrebs hättest, dann hättest du neben Augenflimmern zum Beispiel auch Erbrechen oder starken Durchfall. Also müssen wir eigentlich eingeben, welche Symptome habe ich nicht und welche schon. Und jetzt gibt es ja den Akinator. Das ist ja dieses Ding, wo du an jemanden denken musst, an Prominenten zum Beispiel. Also ein großer Baum, der sich runterpästelt auf seinen Stamm. Und der ist im Prinzip das Wer-bin-ich-Prinzip.
Also du denkst Superman, dann drückst du ein paar Fragen und durch eine errechnete... Prominenten zum Beispiel. Also ein großer Baum, der sich runterhässtet auf seinen Stamm. Und der ist im Prinzip das Wer-bin-ich-Prinzip.
Also du denkst Superman, dann drückst du ein paar Fragen
und durch eine errechnete
so ein Algorithmus
findet der halt relativ schnell heraus, was du denkst.
Weil er einfach, man Frau sortiert und halt immer
maximal die Nenner,
auf die man kommen kann, eingrenzt
und dann hast du halt den schnellsten Weg dahin.
Und das müsste es auch für Diagnostik
geben, dass du einfach kurz, dass du an das denkst, was du hast, Augen flimmern, so, und er kann dann durchfragen. Haben Sie erbrechen? Genau. Dann kannst du schon mal viele Sachen ausschließen. Fühlen Sie sich schwach. Ja, weil ich kann zum Beispiel... Fühlen Sie sich schwach, fühlen Sie sich zerbrechlich, fühlen Sie sich einsam. Grow up. So ein Gifts. Das Ergebnis ist immer, Jesus, halt tief. Ich weiß nicht, wie meine Meinung dazu ist, aber einerseits glaube ich, es ist unglaublich wichtig, dass Ärzte insgesamt als Menschengruppe Integer sind. Dass sie nicht zum Beispiel jetzt klischeehaft sowas wie Anwälte, die irgendwie moralisch dann irgendwelche Lobbyisten verteidigen und so oder irgendwie keine Ahnung, dann irgendwelche Architekten, die irgendwie dann Häuser bauen, die grob gepfuscht ist. Weil, was ich mir zum Beispiel immer denke, ist Fotoarzt. Was du eigentlich willst, ist, du machst ein Foto von deinem Leiden, schickst zu einem Arzt und der sagt, passt, kein Problem, heilt. So instant, genau das willst du doch, weil du gehst erstens nicht dann einfach nicht zum Arzt. Ist ja nicht so, Arzt. Der Arzt würde dann wahrscheinlich jedes Mal sagen, kommen Sie mal rein, muss ich mir angucken. Aber einfach so eine App, Fotoarzt zu haben, wäre schon mal ein Schritt. Aber ich glaube, dass Ärzte einfach sagen, das ist einfach unseriös, weil es gibt ja jemanden, der das anbietet und dann kostet das halt Geld. 50 Cent pro Foto macht jeder, wenn du irgendwie einen komischen gelben Punkt irgendwie auf deiner Haut hast, sofort Fotoarzt, Foto dann und der sagt, ja, wenn es in zwei Tagen nicht abgeheilt ist, gehen Sie mal zu dem Arzt, der kann auch Ärzte empfehlen, die können dann zusammenarbeiten mit der App irgendwie in deiner Gegend. Perfekte App, super, du weißt genau, was los ist. Aber ich glaube, das wird einfach nicht gemacht, weil die haben halt ihren Aristoteles-Eid und dann machen die das halt nicht, ihre Hypotenuse. Ich weiß auch nicht, ich glaube, Fotoarzt ist auch nicht, ich glaube, wir sollten, das würde anders heißen. Gut, Doktor Foto vielleicht, mein Gott, da fällt uns schon was ein. Aber so, das ist ja wie bei, Ärzte sind ja auch Kniffler, also so Rätselliebhaber, die wollen wissen, was, deswegen sind die doch Ärzte, nicht weil die Leute, nicht weil die Leute heilen wollen, die kniffeln gerne um. Die tauschen sie immer die zwei Patienten aus, die zu schwachen.
Nein, die rätseln gerne. Ich glaube, die hätten, also ich habe vielleicht ein bisschen zu viel Doktor ausgeschaut, aber der rätselt halt gerne, dem geht es ja nicht um die Patienten, der will die heilen, weil der das Rätsel lösen will.
So ein überambitionierter Arzt. Und wie sieht Ihr Stuhl aus? Kann ich mal einen kleinen Blick?
Blau.
Ist es blau? Okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, jetzt sagen Sie mir ganz kurz eins, auf drei, auf drei, haben Sie Kopfschmerzen, drei, zwei, eins. Nein. Yes, yes, es ist Krebs. Krebs, Krebs, Krebs, Krebs, Krebs, Krebs, Krebs, Krebs, Krebs, Krebs, aber nicht irgendwas, dem man so heilen kann, wenn der Chemo oder so brauchen würde, Spalentherapie. Aha, so die ersten drei Jahre eines Arztes. Ich denke mir, so ein Fotoarzt war mit Tinder, heisst du kannst nach rechts wischen für ach, boring, du musst nicht kommen. Moment, du suchst dir deinen Arzt aus aus oder was? Nein, der Arzt hat Tinder. Ach so. Der Arzt hat Tinder und sieht Duschiks Foto, also der Fotoarzt bekommt verschiedene Bilder. So wie Sherlock Holmes, der dann die Fälle annimmt, wenn sie interessant sind. Genau, und nach rechts, der hat nichts Schlimmes, so kannst du nach rechts wegwischen. Ja, das ist ein normaler Fuss. Genau, und dann kannst du als Fussmensch dann sagen, oh shit, okay, alles klar, ist nichts Schlimmes. Und in der anderen Richtung heißt dann sowas wie, ah spannend, das ist was Schlimmeres, den nehme ich an. Sondern hast du, kriegst du als Fotoarzt. Du kriegst ein Match zurück und sagst, scheiße, jetzt muss ich zum Arzt. Jetzt können wir, jetzt musst du mir nochmal ein Foto. Du musst chatten dann. Genau, da kann man Fragen beantworten und so weiter. Ey, Online-Diagnostik, ich glaube, da ist noch viel Potenzial. So ein Arzt to go, weil ich habe jetzt, ich war hin und her gerissen. Also ich habe keinen Termin bekommen auf der einen Seite, war zu faul, mich zu kümmern, um, soll ich morgens dann extra eher aufstehen, dahingehen und so weiter, habe jetzt keinen Termin bekommen. So, und dann auf der anderen Seite lese ich, dass ich wahrscheinlich einen Tumor habe im Kopf. Ja, das sind die beiden Lebensrealitäten. Ich schwanke zwischen, oh fuck, ich werde nächsten Monats sterben, ich sollte mich dringend behandeln lassen. So, heute Abend läuft Doktor Haus. Gut, ich will morgen lieber ausschlafen. Kann man Arzt nicht komplett outsourcen? Ich stelle mir da so ein paar Inder in einem Callcenter vor, die irgendwie so Kameras haben. Und du rufst dich per Skype an und zeigst dir dann halt irgendwie deine entzündete Vorhaut. Und dann sagen die so, irgendwas Rassistisches. Und dann schickst du da halt eine Blutprobe hin.
No, ich weiss nicht, es ist keine Krankheit.
Ist das jetzt doppelt rassistisch, wenn du sogar den falschen Akzent machst oder ist das weniger rassistisch?
Ich weiss doch nicht, ich esse so viel Curry und ich liebe den Hindu-Gott und ... Moment mal.
Krishna. Krishna Krabappel. Selbst die Stühle, hörst du die Stühle? Selbst die sind ... Letzte Woche haben wir noch Stühle, die nicht geknarzt haben. Es wird immer lauter, immer mehr Störgeräusche. Lamentierten Florian Thieber Stephan. Ulgten sie herum. Aber das soll man nicht machen, oder was, sagt Stephen King? Stellte Stephen King fest? Nee, soll man nicht sagen, man soll nur sagt sagen. Immer nur sagt, sagt er immer nur sagt, oder was? Ja, tatsächlich. Ich dachte auch, das klingt doch dann redundant, wenn er sagt, Jack sagte, nein, lass das mal lieber sein. Okay, sagte seine Frau, na, aber wir wollen auch mal sehen, wie du damit durchkommst, sagte er dann so. Deswegen lese ich lieber Drehbücher, weil du dich nicht darum kümmern musst, weil du einfach so der, der, der und dann auch Dramen. Oder Dramen, klassische Dramen. Kleist. Du hast kein einziges Stück von Kleist gelesen. Prinz Friedrich von Haunburg. Wie ist Kleist gestorben? Ist ein super, tatsächlich bei einem Bungee-Unglück. Ja, Selbstmord. Ich habe gestern von einem Bungie-Unglück gelesen und das war wirklich was. Das ist so ein Oxymoron eigentlich. Bungie-Unglück. Das funktioniert nicht. Ich finde, das funktioniert ganz gut, weil ich meine, du springst aus einer grossen Höhe und das einzige, was dich vom sicheren Tod trennt, ist ein dünnes Gummiseil. Und wir alle Gummis kennen, wenn wir Leute abflitschen wollen, die reissen. Gummis reissen, das ist ein Problem, das ist ein bekanntes, dem Menschen bekanntes Problem. Wer nicht das erste Leben, das durch einen fehlerhaften Gummi ruiniert wird. Oh! Freddy Mercury. Zum Beispiel. Okay, gut.
Und der ist gerissen oder was? Ein 17-Jähriger hatte ein Bungee-Unglück, hat aber überlebt. Und ich stelle mir vor, das muss so passiert sein, und es ist dann der lächerlichste, es ist gleichzeitig unfassbar schlimm, so ein Bungee-Unglück, aber es ist auch wahnsinnig lächerlich. Weil, stell dir vor, der 17-Jährige, der jetzt überlebt hat, springt, so, landet unten, das Seil ist gerissen, muss ja gerissen sein, am tiefsten Punkt, und der Typ ist gesprungen, runtergesprungen, runtergesprungen, war dann bodennah, dann ist das Seil gerissen, der Typ ist einfach auf dem Boden stehen geblieben und das Seil ist wieder zurück.
Das Seil ist gerissen und wieder zurückgegangen. Ach so. Eigentlich, du bist einfach nur, wenn du mal guckst, langsam gelandet. Man fällt eigentlich gar nicht so hoch, am untersten Punkt. Nee, der ist nicht doll gefallen. Er ist eigentlich nur hingestellt worden von einer großen Höhe. Also das ist was ein furchtbarer... Einfach so sanft gebetet. So, und es kommt so ein ... kommt du hast auch keine zeit irgendwie zu schreien oder zu merken dass du gerade in einem furchtbaren unglück warst weil du einfach nur sanft gelandet bist ja du wurdest sanft auf dem boden abgesetzt und dann ist das seil gerissen und das ist dann denke ich mir was ein unkules unglück so ist es einerseits ein unglück über das man berichten muss weil das furchtbar eigentlich theoretisch hätte enden können, aber so die Fallhöhe, die wortwörtliche Fallhöhe war halt nicht da. Rechtsdruckung und Team. Ja, oder die haben das Gummiband halt nicht befestigt an ihm oder so am Genick befestigt, dass es so gebrochen ist. Er hat überlebt. Das ist ja die Prämisse. Laden wir ihn ein? Apropos einladen. Hey Leute, wir haben richtig gute Nachrichten. Wir haben richtig gute Nachrichten. Nachdem Stefan in seiner neuen Rubrik Medienwatch, wo er immer gegen schlechten Journalismus und gegen schlecht recherchierten Online-Medien und da hat er ein Radiointerview entdeckt mit einer Astronomin, der schlechtest vorangestellt wurde. Und besagte Astronomin hat sich bei uns gemeldet und wird bald Gast im Das-Podcast-Ufo-Podcast-Ufo sein. Oh mein Gott, wie ist das denn? Sie ist durch die halbe Milchstrasse gereist, um bei uns sein zu können. Sie lebt in Boston, in Amerika, und wir werden sie irgendwann zustellen, und darauf könnt ihr euch auf jeden Fall freuen, Anna Frebel heißt sie, Astronomin bei MIT. Am MIT in Boston, also eine der krassesten Hochschulen, wie gesagt, eine der schlauesten Frauen der Welt. Ich will wissen, mein Kopf dreht schon seit Tagen, ich bin schlaflos, und ich frage mich auch die ganze Zeit was ich habe Angst, dass das Interview so wird, wie das, was wir kritisiert haben. Wahrscheinlich. Wahrscheinlich wird es nämlich genauso. Ich bin mir auch ganz interessiert, wie sie darauf gestossen ist, weil wir haben ja nicht lange darüber gesprochen. Entweder hat sie jemand darauf aufmerksam gemacht, wenn es jemand ist, der sie kennt, offensichtlich, muss es auch ein sehr schlauer Mensch sein, oder sie selber, eine der schlauesten Frauen der Welt, hört uns. Beides mal Szenarien, die mich zum Über... Die einzige Frage, die mich interessiert, ist, wenn du der intelligenteste Mensch der Welt bist, wer hält dich davon ab, nur noch Bullshit zu reden? Wenn du wirklich an der Spitze bist, so Stephen Hawking-mäßig, so wirklich so absolute Legende, sein Wort ist Gesetz, wer hält dich davon ab, einfach, wird man nicht auch fa irgendwann zu sagen, so, jeder glaubt dir eh alles. Und dann kannst du einfach, ja, das schwarze Loch ist halt so, dass die halt dann irgendwann explodiert sind und dann saugen die sich wieder zusammen und das hat halt Masse von 16 Millionen Tonnen. Kleinwüchsige sind... Ich verstehe es eh nicht, von daher wir schreiben das jetzt mal auf. Kleinwüchsige sind aber halt keine Menschen, es sind eine ganz andere Rasse. Man kann ruhig Zwerge sagen. Ja, und Giraffen stammen auch von Menschen ab. Ciao! Und alle so, was, was, was, was, und schreiben das nieder. Also all diese Fragen. Warum auch immer, was die Fotos machen. Aber das ist wirklich eine spannende Frage. Gefühlt sagt Stephen Hawking auch seit drei Jahren nur noch Bullshit. Er behauptet, dass die Menschheit in h 100 Jahren nicht mehr da ist. Ist er jetzt eigentlich mit Siri zusammen?
Oh, da kaut er aber schon lange drauf rum.
Nein, als ob ich da lange drauf kauen würde.
Du hast ihn gerade von deiner Hand vorgelesen.
Quatsch.
Nein, ich freue mich auf jeden Fall sehr
auf Frau Professorin Frevel,
die wir hier zu Gast haben.
Wir müssen noch gucken, wie das in der Zeitzone ist.
Mein Handy macht immer Frevel aus ihrem Namen.
Frevel? Frevel.
Ich spreche das Vogel-V noch wie ein W aus. Vogel. Frevel? Ich bin gespannt. Ich habe mir schon ein paar Fragen aufgeschrieben. Falls ihr auch Fragen habt an eine Astronomin, es geht um Schwerkraft, es geht um Lichtjahre, was macht das Licht da draußen eigentlich die ganze Zeit? Es geht um Sterne, es geht um Planeten, es geht um Pluto. Ich bin gespannt, wie wir dieses kontroverse Thema angehen. Ist natürlich ein heikles Thema. Ich habe das Gefühl, da zucken alle Astronomen zusammen. Ich werde auch nicht mit meinem Pluto-Shirt kommen, ich werde mit einem neutraleren Shirt kommen. Erde vielleicht, Erde glaube ich ist allgemein akzeptiert im Astronomen-Business. Ich bin ganz gespannt. Außerirdische natürlich, Zeitreisen, Wurmloch, wann geht es endlich ins Wurmloch? Wurmloch, Maulwurf, warum Wurmloch? Ach so, weil es ja so ein Wurm, das geht ja von einer Dimension in die andere. Ja, genau. Und dann ist es ja durch so eine Grundverbindung. Ja, genau, durch verschiedene schwarze Löcher, sagt man ja. Es ist dann gemeinsam verbunden. Oh, die wird uns so fertig machen, einfach wenn wir so Bullshit reden, einfach so. Und irgendwie so, ja, nicht ganz verschwindet. Nee, stimmt nicht, ich weiß schon viel. Ja, das werden wir mal sehen, wie viel du weißt. Das ist nämlich genau das Stephen Hawking-Komplex, dass du nämlich denkst, du hättest viel Ahnung und deswegen hier bullshiten kannst, weil dich niemand callt, aber Frevel wird dich callen. Und dann steht immer da. Und außerdem, erklären wir, du mir mal, du könntest mir nicht die Relativitätstheorie erklären jetzt, du könntest mir die nicht erklären. Ich könnte die nicht erklären. Weil ich keine Freitags habe,
keine Hobbys habe, seit 28 Jahren Single bin und deswegen
diese Dokus gucke die ganze Zeit.
Relativitätstheorie ist ein ganz simples Prinzip.
Wenn du eine Uhr auf den Mars schickst,
dann werden die Leute ernsthafte
Fragen stellen, was das soll
und warum.
Und dann ist halt auch die Sommerzeitfrage.
Winterzeit schwierig. Genau. Mist, ich dachte, du kriegst es nicht so gut hin. Nee, ich habe mir tatsächlich schon ein paar Fragen überlegt, weil ich finde, wir sollten auch mal wirklich eine Hi-Bro-Brow. Hi-Bro ist eigentlich gut, ne? Wir machen die Hey-Bro-Folge. Wir sind mal gespannt. Hey-Bro-What's-up-Folge. Und ich habe mir tatsächlich schon ein paar Fragen überlegt, weil es gibt auch ein paar Sachen, die mich interessieren. Du wirst dann Fragen stellen, die niemand versteht, weil du dich selber interessierst. Ich habe doch einen enormen, ich habe einen Riegel an Sendebewusstsein. Da kannst du noch nicht mal deinen Mund aufkriegen, so dick ist der. Da kannst du nicht mal deine Zähne vergraben drin. Ich will mir nicht hier aber noch über Sendebewusstsein oder über deinen Geschäftsorgan sprechen. Ich freue mich wirklich wahnsinnig auf die Folge. Total. Mal gucken, wie wir das hinkriegen. Vor allem müssen wir auch gucken, wie wir sie aus Boston zugeschalten haben, weil das ist ja auch eine andere Zeit gerade. Da ist ja auch gerade Winter. Da wissen wir auch nicht, wie wir das jetzt hinkriegen, dass wir die dazuschalten können. Mal gucken. Wie viel Zeitverschriebung? Sechs Stunden? Sechs Stunden zurück, glaube ich. Ja, also da ist jetzt eins. Also gut, völlig in Ordnung. Mal gucken. Der alte Gag, den man machen könnte, ist, wir können ihr sagen, was in der Zukunft passiert. Aber den sparen wir uns jetzt mal lieber. Gut. Du warst doch mal im Callcenter, oder? Ja, im Callcenter gearbeitet. Service-Hotlines sind unglaublich makaber. Ich musste jetzt tatsächlich ganz viele Anrufe tätigen, weil mein Internet plötzlich weg war. Und dann gab es ein paar Komplikationen mit der Telekom. Und dann habe ich da angerufen. Und ich weiß nicht, wie du an solche Sachen herangehst. Unsere Kollegin Katjana, die kennt ja gar nichts und fordert direkt den Vorgesetzten. Straight. Ist direkt auf 180. Das war sehr beeindruckend. Wir haben sie beobachtet, wie sie auf dem Weg nach New York um ihre Kriegkarte gekämpft hat. Ständigerweise hat ihre Kriegkarte gesperrt, das ist nicht nur ein Grund, um sauber zu sein. Aber ich bin komplett, fahre das komplette Gegenprogramm. Ja, ich würde mir also vor den Praktikanten geben lassen. Ich will wirklich erst mal mit dem wirklich Niedersten in der ganzen Firma reden. Ich bin ein anderer Mensch, wenn ich irgendwo einrufe. Ich bin kein Mensch. Ich bin einfach das Gute. Ich bin einfach das vereinte G Die Essenz, du bist das Weiße von jen und jang. Es ist unglaublich, ich rufe dann da an und sage wirklich, hey, hallo, schönen guten Tag, mein Name ist Stefan Thiese und ich habe dieses kleine Problem, vielleicht, ich würde mich freuen, wenn Sie mir dabei helfen könnten. Vielleicht liegt es auch an mir. Vielleicht liegt es an mir, wahrscheinlich liegt es an mir, vielen Dank, dass Sie sich die Zeit genommen haben, mir dabei zu helfen und ich denke, ich denke mir die ganze Zeit, dem Menschen, welchen würde ich am liebsten helfen, dem unterwürfigsten, sich am clever, also der zumindest, man denkt, der versteht was von der Materie, der ist nicht ein Typ, der einfach einen Stecker vergessen hat, reinzumachen. Man will schon so ein bisschen was, so fachliches Wissen mitnehmen. Der schon selber ein bisschen gedacht hat, bevor er angerufen hat. Der auch schon mal gegoogelt hat, der auch schon mal erwähnt hat, dass er schon mal gegoogelt hat und so. Und so einer bin ich, ich bin einfach das personifizierte Gute und die haben mich weggedrückt. Und dann denke ich mir... Weggedrückt? Die haben mich ganz oft weggedrückt einfach, die haben mich in so Warteschleifen gebracht. Also sie haben mich dann zum Festnetzbereich geschickt, der Festnetzbereich hat mich wieder zurückgeschickt und während die mich verbunden haben, haben sie aufgelegt jedes Mal. Und dann, ich habe wieder neu angerufen und gesagt,
hey, Ihre Kollegen haben mich gerade wohl aus Versehen,
bin ich da irgendwie in der Warteschleife gelandet und dann ist die irgendwann auch ausgegangen, deswegen war ich dann nicht mehr in der Leitung
und so weiter und war immer so mega freundlich
und die haben mich immer weiter weggedrückt.
Und ich dachte, ich habe dann offensichtlich ein Problem gehabt, was sie nicht lösen konnten.
Im Nachhinein hat sich herausgestellt, ich hätte einfach
einen Vorgesetzten fragen müssen, weil die mir jedes Mal
helfen konnten, weil da ist irgendwie eine
Sicherheitsstufe drin, die dann irgendwie, können die dann auf den Knopf drücken und mir so einen Gutschein geben, dann ging alles und so weiter, führt zu sehr ins Detail, aber die hätten mir helfen können und die Angestellten halt nicht. Heißt mit Katjanas Taktik wäre ich viel besser gefahren, aber zeigt mir also, dass dieses personifizierte Gute, dieser widerliche Brocken, schleimende Brocken wird weggedrückt von Menschen. Er bleibt hängen. Was sind das für Menschen, die
so jemanden wegdrücken? Ja.
Was sind das, wie
sind die im Alltag?
Oder ist einfach das personifizierte
Gute einfach furchtbar nervig und anstrengend?
Ja, es ist ja die Frage, suchen sie
jemanden, den sie bemitleiden können, oder suchen sie jemanden
auf Augenhöhe, der genauso verzweifelt und genauso
wenig Spaß in seinem Leben hat, wie man selbst,
wo man sagt, mit dem kann ich auf einer anderen Ebene connecten, weil du bist ja komplett am Boden, wenn du im Callcenter arbeitest, du bist ja den ganzen Tag geschunden einfach, du hast ja keinen guten Gedanken mehr in deinem Kopf. Und wenn dann jemand auf dich zukommt, der dann so, hallo, ich bin der Stefan, hi, du, kann sein, es liegt vielleicht auch an mir, irgendwie, kann ich dir ein Tee anbieten und so, okay, dann denkst du ja auch einfach, ja, gesterben, du hast zu viel Spaß in deinem Leben.
Abgestimmt.
Geht das nicht in deren Statistik rein oder so?
Es ist so ein schönes Machtgefühl, Leute in die Schleife zu hören.
Es macht süchtig, es macht wirklich süchtig.
Und du denkst, vor allem, du wirst da irgendwann so darauf gedreht, dass du selbst im Alltag,
wenn du mit jemandem sprichst, so dein Finger
suchst, so die Warteschleifentaste,
weil du so gewohnt bist, unangenehme Gespräche,
so von wegen, ich muss ganz kurz mit meinem Vorgesetzten sprechen und ich kümmere mich gleich wieder um sie. Zack, und du holst dir einen Kaffee, trinken, schaust im Fenster. Und dann hast du mir solche Sachen immer gehalten, dass du einen anderen Namen genannt hast sogar. Ja, genau, habe ich noch. Und dann habe ich den, ich habe jedem im Gespräch zehnmal nach einem Namen gefragt, in der Hoffnung, er spricht sich mal irgendwann, weil ich dachte mir, dann ist mir gerade in so einem Smalltalk-Gespräch, und jetzt fragst du ihn nur einen Namen. Wie war ihr Name nochmal? Und dann dass er irgendwie kurz vergisst, dass er sich als Batman ausgibt. Ich habe auch immer, wenn es hieß, geben Sie meinen Vorgesetzten, immer alles klar, gut. Hallo, guten Tag, wie kann ich Ihnen helfen? Nein, das sind nicht immer... Nein, natürlich, das sind doch Sie. Das sind doch schon wieder Sie. Ich glaube, es sind 22.30 Uhr, wenn ich da die Nachtschicht schiebe, dann klingel ich noch meinen Vorgesetzten raus. Gibt es denn überhaupt diesen Vorgesetzten? Ich habe es nie ernsthaft zu dem Vorgesetzten gemeint. Ich habe immer dann irgendeine andere Person imitiert. Oder auch zu meinem Kollegen aus der Post habe ich auch manchmal, der den ganzen Tag Briefumschläge geleckt hat und einfach komplett debil war schon und dem das dann gegeben. Und dann hat der es wieder zurückgebracht. Dieser Kleber kann auch nicht gut sein. Schrecklich, ganz schrecklich. Hat er noch eine Zunge gehabt oder war die Zunge vorne? Wie so ein Basketball sah die aus, so ganz so rumpelig. Ach so, ich dachte eher wie so ein Stempelkissen, wo die auch dann so diese Poststempel drauf machen können. Aber gibt es den Vorgesetzten, kann man, gibt es den theoretisch? Also mein Vorgesetzter wäre dann nicht, der hätte weder helfen können, noch hätte der Lust gehabt. Du warst auch in so einer Zeugen Jehova-Karte. Ich habe mich in so eine Art Sekte gefangen. Das war schon, nee, aber das, also ich habe da, mir war es scheißegal. Also vor allem, das ist ja so, wenn du gefeuert wirst, so what so? Die können dich auch nicht feuern. Dein Vorgesetzter ist der Kunde noch egal. Dann wurdest du gefeuert von einem Job, den du eh schon nicht wolltest. Ja, dann so, uh, jetzt habe ich Freizeit. Oh, ich werde vom Callcenter gefeuert. Wie schlimm kann mein Leben sein? Völlig egal, Aber es hat Spaß gemacht. Cool. Also warum die Nachtschichten einfach so alleine in der Grossstadt irgendwie und dann andere verlorene Seelen rufen dich an. Ey, was ich wirklich gerne machen würde, ich würde wirklich gerne die Lateline moderieren. Ja. Ich würde wirklich gerne einfach so eine nachtnächtliche Hilfesendung moderieren. Aber nicht, dass ich da wie Dominik anfange, den Leuten dann wirklich aktiv zu helfen, sondern einfach, ich will einfach nur, ich will einfach nur nachts irgendwo zum Studio fahren. Ich finde es cool, nachts zu arbeiten, das Gefühl, das zu müssen. Alle schlafen gehen, alle legen sich hin, die Stadt ist ruhig, du fährst irgendwo hin, gehst ins Studio, alles dunkel. Ist an sich cool, aber dann rufen da halt Leute an, die dann halt dir deine Insider immer vorballern. Stefan Witze, dein Name heißt Witze mit nachnamen Titze und du denkst ja halt, geh sterben. Alles klar, ich stelle euch durch. Und dann musst du selber irgendwie dann auch das Unterhaltungsvakuum von denen dann noch selber füllen. Also es ist schwierig. Und du hörst dich die ganze Zeit so ganz laut auf den eigenen Kopfhörern. Hallo hier ist die Leitlein, guten Abend, schönen guten Tag. Wen darf ich in Le Leitung begrüssen? Und wenn der nervt, dann drückst du... Hallo, hier ist die Mareike. Ja, hallo Mareike, wie geht's dir? Hallo, guten Tag. Na, heute schon Fehlkauf gemacht, Stefan? Haha, oh, einen Moment, da muss ich dich wohl wegdrücken. Ciao. Hallo, wen habe ich in der Leitung? Hallo, hier ist der Justin. Hallo Justin, wie ist dir? Hi. Na, bist du mit deinem Booster-Ball wieder hingefallen? Soll ich den... Und wen habe ich jetzt in der Leitung? Hallo, hier ist der Klaus. Hallo Klaus, wie geht's dir? Hallo, Mensch, sag mal, passt du überhaupt ins Studio, so groß wie du bist? Das stimmt, ich bin ein bisschen größer. Und das war's von Klaus. Und so geht das zweieinhalb Stunden lang. Jeden Dienstag. Aber ich hab ne gute Nacht. Jeden Dienstag. Ich krieg einfach ein Bar auf die Kralle, ein Tausi jede Folge.
Ja, vergiss es. Ja, weiß ich nicht, was sie bekommen. Jeden Dienstag schön beleidigen lassen von Leuten. Darauf willst du auch hinauslaufen. Weil ich bin, wie gesagt, ich bin der Mensch, da hinten in der Ecke gekrümmt sitzt und Angst hat, dass man in der falschen Ecke des Raumes sitzt. Und dann kommen halt Leute, die sich die ganze Nacht einfach beleidigen. Der Mensch hat einen urmenschlichen Instinkt, nicht der Schwächste zu sein. Das heißt, du wirst immer, deswegen grausam sind die Menschen, wenn sie ganz unten sind. Die grösste Grausamkeit ist zwischen der Nummer 0 und 1. Also wenn jetzt irgendwie, keine Ahnung, 20 ist der Anführer. Das ist immer noch einen hinter dir, den du umbringen kannst. Weil sobald du 1 bist, denkst du dir, ja okay, ich bin einigermaßen okay. Wenn es irgendwie heißt, oh, jemand hat den Honig geklaut, können wir alle die Null kaputt machen. Ich bin immer noch, dann bin ich zwar die Null, aber das ist okay. Du willst nicht der Schlechtste sein, weil die Evolution tötet ja immer die Schwächsten aus. Das heißt, solange du nicht der Schwächste bist, ist alles okay. Zwischen 19 und 20, klar, die Evolution tötet die aus, die nicht rammeln, Florentin, die nicht schnackseln. Ich sag's dir, Alter, die nicht ordentlich meine wegwämsen, die werden ausgesiehen. Das Originalmanuskript von Darwin war so versaut, was er da beschrieben hat, wie diese Langschnabel-Moskitos. Moinsen, Darwin hier wieder, Alter, Vater, hab ich heute diese scheiß Schnäbel, diese Schnäbeltiere beobachtet. Ey, diese Schnäbel, die wämsen aber auch nicht genug, die sind weg in zehn Jahren. Die haben sich rumgewämst, weil die hier ihre fucking Gene da nicht vernünftig weitergegeben haben, weil die fucking nicht schnackseln. Darwin am Campusradio, es ist eine Sketchshow, die für immer laufen könnte von mir. Darwin macht Campusradio, drei Leute hören zu, zwei sind Sponsoren. Alter, Davi Davi Davi, 95 hier wieder. Hey, was geht bei euch? Survival of the fittest, fittest, fittest, music, music. Jetzt kommt erst mal Survival of Queen. Viel Spaß mit Rolling Stones. Man kann alles in dieser Stimme sagen und es funktioniert einfach. Völlig egal, völlig irrelevant. Ja, verschiedene historische Figuren machen Campus-Radio, finde ich. Hier ist Jinkis Khan und Abram Lincoln. Viel Spaß. Hey Abe, ich dachte mir, ich würde heute gerne mal das Gemeine Volk der Perser einnehmen. Was sagst du dazu? Ja, ich bin mir nicht so hundertprozentig sicher. Ich finde, dass wir als ein Volk da zusammenhalten sollen. Ja, ach. Und was ist eigentlich mit dem Kaffee? Du trägst lächerliche Mut. Tatsächlich habe ich letztens gehört, er hatte eine hohe Stimme. Ey, es gibt von Wired, ey ohne Scheiß meine kleine Empfehlung an der Stelle. Niemand versteht unser Radio. Der YouTube-K des Magazins The Wired hat so eine Reihe mit einem Linguisten, mit einem Sprachtrainer. Und der guckt sich dann die verschiedenen Serien an. Der guckt sich dann zum Beispiel Schauspieler an, wie die Dialekte imitieren und kritisiert der, oder jetzt die dritte Folge kam gerade raus, wie Schauspieler echte Personen, also Ideolekte, also der ganz persönliche Stil eines Sprechens von jedem Menschen persönlich. Ja, das hat gerade Ideolekte auch ans Whiteboard geschrieben. Vielen Dank dafür. Und das ist so eine geile Serie. Ja. Und die ist cool, weil ich finde, was die gut machen, ist die, weil oft sagt man ja so, ja, den Zuschauer nicht überfordern, den Zuschauer nicht, sorry, dass ich kurz den Zuschauer nicht überfordern, irgendwie an die Hand nehmen und die schaffen es immer, der benutzt auch so Fachbegriffe und so, aber auf eine Art, wo du denkst, cool, du weißt, der Typ hat brutal drauf und der ist ultra sympathisch und es ist immer einfach cool, Leute Dialekte zu hören und einfach Leute zu hören, die ihre Stimme perfekt beherrschen, das ist immer cool und der benutzt dann immer auch so Dialekte, so Fachbegriffe und das ist richtig cool. Kann er auch Dialekte nachmachen oder weiss er nur, was sich er anschaut?
Alles klar, der ist ja Sprachcoach, der muss, wenn jemand sagt, so, ja, was kriegst du, wir morgen Bayern spielen, dann sagt er, ja, hier, da musst du linguale...
Und ein Tennistrainer ist auch nicht der beste Tennisspieler.
Ich glaube da schon, da ist es schon so.
Ein Baumfall, Baumung.
Der kann halt nicht gut Schauspielen, aber der beherrscht die Sprache schon perfekt, würde ich sagen.
Vielleicht, ich weiß nicht.
Mittlerweile gibt es ja auch wirklich Wissenschaftler, Sprachwissenschaftler, die Sprachen für Serien erfinden. Ja, da gibt es auch Folge zwei davon. Es gibt halt einen krassen Typen, der diese ganzen Sprachen von Game of Thrones erfunden hat, die man theoretisch alle sprechen kann. Und er hat sich tierisch über Star Wars abgefuckt, weil da halt einfach Nonsens gebrabbelt wird. Aber bei Game of Thrones hat sich jemand halt hingesetzt, er, und hat halt einfach Sprachen erfunden, die eine Grammatik haben, die angelehnt sind an verschiedene Sprachen, die es gibt, sei es jetzt die Mongolen, die Mongos, die Basten. Ist das eine Ehrung, wenn die Sprache der Klingonen nachempfunden wurde nach deiner Sprache und denkst du so, Leute, Italienisch vielleicht? Hallo, warum denn jetzt wir, sind jetzt wir die krassen Monster? Ihr sprecht so blablabla. Eure Sprache ist in unserem Ohr Sprache wie blablabla. Okay, Leute, wir haben wunderbare Musik und Gedichte. Diese Karl-Drogos, wie heissen die nochmal dieses Volk?
Dothraki. Ja, die Dothraken.
Die sind nämlich nachempfunden,
nach hier Genghis Khan und Mongolei und all so
so eine Fatzkes.
Die sind so im Osten.
Weit im Osten. Stimmt schon, ja.
Und wie denken denn die Leute, die das gucken,
die da wohnen, die alle so aussehen wie
Karl Drogo und sich abends
Game of Thrones angucken, alle mit ihren langen Pferdeschwänzen, oberkörperfrei in ihren Lehmhütten Game of Thrones gucken. Wie nehmen die denn den wahr? Und sind die nicht unfassbar sauer, wenn ist nicht deren Karl Drogo allein kulturell so deren Protagonist? Ja, das ist Rassismus gegen Leute, die sich nicht wehren können. Das kotzt mich einfach an. Das ist einfach scheisse. Sorry. Aber es gibt auch tatsächlich in England ein Theater, die Shakespeare spielen, und zwar so, wie sie glauben, dass man damals auch Worte ausgesprochen hat. Also wenn man das heute liest, dann spricht man das halt so aus wie, dann hat es halt House, House. Aber es kann ja sein, dass es irgendwie die ganz anders irgendwie Hose ausgesprochen haben, so weiß man ja nicht so. Und deswegen, die versuchen, die nehmen die ganzen Rose before house. Die nehmen die ganzen Texte und gucken, wo teilweise auch so Reime nicht mehr funktionieren, weil man die Worte anders ausspricht. Und die versuchen, sich dadurch zu rekonstruieren, wo sie dachten, ah, das war wahrscheinlich ein Reim. Sehr verwirrend. Oder irgendwie, wo Dinge ähnlich klangen, wo dann, keine Ahnung, der Familienname so ähnlich klang wie ein berühmtes Bordell in London damals. Das Stück, was wir eben gesehen haben, war entweder sehr gut oder sehr schlecht. Oder es war einfach Nonsen. Ich habe es nicht verstanden. Und das ist auch ein cooles Video, haue ich vielleicht auch mal raus, so ein Video von so einem Vater, der ist so Sprachwissenschaftler, der rekonstruiert ist und der Sohn ist Schauspieler und muss das dann alles dann vortragen, wo man dann auch weiß, ob das eine gesunde Vater-Sohn-Beziehung ist. Aber es ist ganz interessant, weil die halt dann wirklich Dinge, die man einfach nicht wissen kann, versuchen zu rekonstruieren. Es wird ja auch dann teilweise, gibt es Konzerte, wo die Bach so spielen, wie die denken, dass Bach das wollte. Weil damals, sagt man, wurden Stücke auch viel, viel langsamer gespielt als jetzt. Ich dachte, schneller. Nee, viel, viel langsamer. Viel, viel, viel langsamer.
Mittlerweile ist das alles viel schneller.
Das geht nicht so.
Das war nicht ba ba ba ba.
Nee, das war deren, war auch ein langsameres Leben.
Das ist ja wirklich so.
Man kommt mittlerweile schnell von an nach.
Die sind mit 24 gestorben.
Das war ein wesentlich schnelleres Leben.
Ja, aber die hatten da schon acht Kinder zu einem Feier.
Die haben viel langsamer gesprochen,
weil die Zeit auch viel langsamer vergangen ist.
Erst mal relativ, schade Sie, Rüge. Je weiter es hinterliegt, desto... Nee, es war ja auch so, man erklärt das immer so, dass Kutsche, Auto, Pferd, diese ganze Evolution, wie man gefahren ist und so, das war alles ein bisschen langsamer. Und so erklärt man sich, dass die Stücke waren eher so ba ba ba ba ba. Wow, langsam, langsam, sorry, sorry, ich komme nicht mit. Können wir noch, Entschuldigung, das geht mir viel zu schnell. Ba, ba und was? Hey, nein, zunächst kommt ein ba, dann noch ein ba, und dann noch ein ba, und dann ein ba. Ah, okay, verstehe. Okay. Und man glaubt auch, dass sie ein bisschen langsamer gesprochen haben. Ey, Rap-Musik muss so lehm gewesen sein. Also, I gotta hip, harp, the hip, the hip, the hip, the hip. Mein Name ist Stefan, das Fun steht für Spaß. Draussen scheint die Sonne auf das grüne Brass. Ich bin sehr froh, dass man so besser freestylen kann. Ich würde sagen, du wäre echt ein besserer Mann.g, die Schweden! Die Schweden! Schweden! Hey, die Schweden! So auf dem Ausguckturm. Hey, Leute! Da kommt die Schweden-Katapulten. Okay, ich. Was? Die Steine der Katapulte sind wesentlich langsamer geflogen. Obacht, jetzt gleich trifft er uns ...
Ach.
Ja, dann ist das tragische Ende gestorben am Mittag.
Das war eine wilde Zeit damals, ne?
Ruhiger, entspannter.
Ruhiger, ja, aber auch gefährlicher.
Ich glaube ...
Wir sollten mal so ein Mittelalterwochenende machen.
Das Podcast-Ufo, das Podcast-Ufey, so ein Y.
Hört, hört, Handgeklapper! Wir wünschen euch eine wohlgesonnene Woche und viel Spaß bei all eurem Treiben.
Bei den sieben Sonnen und sieben Dunkelheiten wünschen wir euch viel Erfolg. Bei der Kraft des Lichtvaters wünsche ich euch hopp, hopp, hopp und viel Spaß und bis zum nächsten Mal, wenn es wieder heisst, dass der Podcastmann trifft ein und verliest die lautere Kunde.